Great to hear from you.
Why don't we check in with.
Oh, I don't know. Maybe David from the United
Kingdom. David from London. You're on the air.
Hi. Can you hear me? I can. Hey.
So it's sort of been following me for about a
year now. Pleasure. I had a really dying question
during the election, which I guess it was more of
a difference between how the UK won the elections
and the Americans. Yes. And I found it so bizarre
the way results came out piecemeal, like
bit by bit, because in the UK we kind of
announce the results when everything's been
counted. Right. And it just struck me as so
bizarre that Trump kept talking about massive
dumps and went to bed and then he was off and
then he was down. And I really didn't understand
why the US system was like that. And I just yeah,
it was just a dying question. I was speaking
with one of my American friends about
thing, and he didn't understand why either.
And I don't I don't have an answer as to why,
other than to say that it's been this way for
a long time. I'm I don't know if you could even
restrict I mean, listen, you know, as we have
50 states and the states collect results from
the individual counties and municipalities, I just
don't know if you could even could you even tell
everybody do not release any information until
I just don't know. It is it is sort of strange.
It just like, yeah, it would be it would
have it would have stopped this whole kind of
angle of, you know, Fox News saying,
oh, well, you know, it really wouldn't
and here's why it wouldn't prevent it.
Here's the problem, David. Imagine that there's
a there's a different system where the numbers are
announced, when they are final, when it's really
close like it was in Georgia. If they said, hey,
we it's been eight days, we now have the results,
then Trump and Fox News and others would just say
eight days. That's really suspicious. I'm sure
they spent that time manipulating the numbers
so it actually wouldn't solve the problem.
Guess you're damned if you do, damned if you
don't. Yes, they're always going to have some
kind of opinion against why it's not correct.
Absolutely. Yeah, I just wanted to say, again,
like, been following you for about a year. And
I honestly, I come home after work while I'm
mainly working from home. But come back and I
think around 8:00, 9:00 p.m. your show kicks
in. I actually start your live stream habit
in the background top when the music kicks in,
although lately the music hasn't kicked in
that much, which I've been a bit disappointed.
We're doing more like music lately.
We've got some good new good new tracks.
We've been I'm not quite you know,
I could be watching something else
or eating dinner with my girlfriend.
Right. Right. I'm sorry. I have to stop.
Well, I appreciate it. I appreciate it. What
a what part of London are you in generally?
So I live in Catford.
Which is a comfort, yeah, if she's of
southeast London, so I work and I work in Peckham,
which you may or may not know, South London again.
So this is all this is all
south of the river. Right.
And south of the river. Yes.
Understood. I did go to a pub
in a working sort of a blue. I don't know
what the right term is. Working class,
blue collar. I don't want to say the wrong word.
Airplanes south of the river with my cousin
when I was in London. And it was quite an
experience. It was sort of like a soccer pub,
I guess I would say, OK, yeah, I'm fantastic.
Well, I mean, if you're next in London,
I don't know if we can even travel between the
US and the UK right now. I guess you can't,
but if you're ever in London and wanted to do a
talk or anything like that, I would definitely be
one to come and watch you give a lecture or
something like that. And I'm trying to spread
the word to my colleagues and friends around
about you and how you do these live streams
and know. I just think it's really great. My
friend, actually, he he'd never seen someone
I live tweet and live stream before
as a kind of way to like our content.
He found the whole thing kind of fascinating.
And I've kind of got him into watching you now.
And I send all the links out to my friends
when when you come on. It's really great.
Well, thank you. I appreciate
the support from across the pond.
All right.
Thank you very much.
There is David from London, England. That is all
the time I have today. Four calls via discord.
I'm sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody, but we will take calls again.